[Music]
I hadn't had any of the books but I was
recording some music for one of the
television shows I've directed and in
between each recording session the
orchestra were all reading Potter so it
was very clear that everyone was
incredibly into these stories that Joe
had been creating when I went to read
the books there was something wonderful
and authentic about Joe's exploration of
what it was growing up in a straw did
environments were magical and
extraordinary but the emotional truths
were rooted in the real world and it
immediately appealed hallows was quite
an expensive book and I felt you could
create two interesting films with
Hallows Part 1 an independent much more
intimate movie on Harry Ron and a Himani
are out in the real world for the very
first time having to learn some really
hard life lessons and the second part
was more of a blockbuster entertaining
conclusion to the whole series which
felt much more appropriate that we went
out with a very final confrontation
between older Mort and Harry Potter the
sequence is about a boys facing down
this nemesis this demon that had haunted
him here his childhood this is the
figure that had killed his parents I was
keen to explore this unique relationship
between Voldemort and Harry Harry
Caray's the spirit of Voldemort and they
have this unity and I had this idea that
as they confronted each other at the top
of a school trying stuff and Harry would
grab aldermore and actually pull him off
this tower and they evacuated the school
together and we'd explore this weird
visual synthesis that exists between the
two of them and they'd eventually tumble
down into the courtyard in the book that
confrontation takes place in the Great
Hall but I always wanted to get a feel
of a Western Hill away from an audience
and so we move to this first court you
are taking it into this down-and-dirty
place where it was literally a scramble
in the mud to finally decide who was
going to win this battle that had been
going on for such a long time it was
absolutely freezing and damn see for
practically chattering as was race
because it was a brutal winter that year
so that added authenticity when you're
bringing a series of major stories or
epic conclusion one never really
it's about the pressure or having to
deliver something that people are going
to be satisfied with you just get your
head down and you explore it in the best
way that you feel is right it was the
end of journalist answers and with those
world so I think that was probably the
biggest challenge knowing that
expectations were sky high and that
people wanted to have a properly
satisfying emotional resolution to this
series of stories and I think we did it